or even if you had it you must be like
what is this TOC wizardry you know this
is for unit stuff why are we learning
this ok so just as an introduction okay
implicit differentiation is a method for
differentiating of functions and
relations okay
it is a four unit method it's explicitly
sitting it is defined in the pointed
syllabus point of people have to learn
it and three people don't however I'm
going to teach it to you anyway here's
why number one oh it's not that hard
it's just the chain rule that's all it
is okay
just as a fancy name okay says number
one number two it is extraordinarily
useful for related rates questions okay
and you'll see why in a minute hopefully
so implicit differentiation let's start
off by saying you know how to
differentiate stuff already
so why learn a new method this is not
like the chain rule or pry tool or
questionable like it lets you do a whole
new family of functions when when do you
use implicit differentiation okay so
because this is a whole new idea and I'm
going to try and cram in a related rates
example after this let me give it to you
let me just put in a sentence okay we
use this where functions or or relations
actually I'm going to my first example
will be a relation I thought to find
explicitly in terms all
now I am trying to arm and try again
struggling to come up with a simple and
so not overly techy but also concise way
to say this so I couldn't do concise so
I'm gonna try and go as simple it's when
functions aren't defined explicitly in
terms of the variable that we want to
differentiate with respect to okay
because by now it's no it's no new idea
that when you get a function there's
multiple variables of variables in there
and you can differentiate with respect
to different ones and of course it means
totally different things when you
differentiate with respect to time or
with respect to a radius or in sort of
time okay so let me give you the example
the kinds of functions we've met before
very simple things like saying is right
okay this is a function y and it is to
find explicitly in terms of all the X's
being over over here right so I can
differentiate with them just respect to
X quite simply okay because I know rules
I've got my rules for logs and I'm a
chain rule there problems okay but well
you made something like say this
relations commonly do this let's say a
circle okay so circle Center origin
radius five but when you're like okay if
I were to differentiate this with
respect to X suppose I would have asked
you a question to do with the gradient
of this relationship which I am going to
in a second what would you be able to do
with it but what would you have to do
with it if you won't do wire the X right
I've current methods require that I have
y equals something okay and then you
apply your normal rules to differentiate
okay so how would we do it without doing
that rearrangement okay
so firstly before I show you that which
is the implicit part let's just do it
normally okay
suppose I'm interested in what is the
gradient of this relation at
this point three four okay because this
is a circle
okay so three four is up here okay so
you're going to be expecting something
that corresponds to do that tangent okay
so how do we stop what I do first
any takers I want I want Y as a subject
so first thing we're gonna do is check
out the X Squared's all of this and then
if I want Y
I'll take square root of both sides okay
now because I'm taking the square root I
have to say plus or minus well plus or
minus really means this is not one
function but to write which is what you
want to expect because I've got the top
half and I've got the bottom half okay
now that I have wires a subject I want
differentiate so which one should I
differentiate this is this is why I drew
the diagram for you to our plus or minus
I will plus right because I'm interested
in that half of the circle okay so I'm
gonna take this okay so remember by the
way the real y is both of them but this
is the one I'm particularly interested
in in this case so now I say you and yet
okay so chain rule yes this is 25 minus
x squared to the power of 1/2 so
differentiate the inside which is minus
2x and they don't differentiate the
outside which is bring the power down so
the power is off and then reduce the
power by one solve on 25 minus x squared
power of minus half yes
okay so let's just tidy that up a little
bit I should have minus x over
that happy so far so good
so that's simple enough and now I'm
wondering at a specific point right so
I'll take the x value and I'll pop it in
I'll say when x equals 3 dy DX is equal
to on the top I'm gonna have minus 3 and
on the denominator I've got the square
root of 25 minus 9 25 minus 9 is 16 so
the square root of that is 4
ok so happy with that so find that sort
of matches what we expected as well as
negative and it's kind of shallow so
great now I'm going to show you how do
we approach this using using implicit
differentiation okay and in this case
it's not that bad
to do it this way okay but the method
will be useful we're having a look at
the related rates questions so what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna start back at
this loan x squared plus y squared is
equal to 20 okay now with regular all
differentiation because I need to make Y
the subject I start to rearrange okay
but implicit differentiation says just
start wherever you like okay then and
just start to differentiate with respect
to the variable that you've chosen okay
so how in that work I'll have three
terms here right so I'm gonna
differentiate each one separately with
respect to X okay so here I'm going to
say do yet the first term is x squared
plus DX of Y squared which is the second
one and then DX of 25 okay so out of the
three terms
two of these are quite easy to handle
right because the derivative of x
squared is 2x and the derivative of 25
is it's just a constant so it's zero
okay but then you get to this guy what
do we do with him okay now I told you
implicit differentiation is just a fancy
name for chain rule just in this
specific example okay so how look at
this right it's confusing because you're
like there's no exit what do I do with
this
well what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
treat why rather than as a variable as a
permanent rule I'm going to treat Y as a
function because that is indeed what it
is right
y is equal to its it's shorthand for a
whole bunch of other stuff okay so if Y
is it function let's just come over here
okay it's the function squared okay
treat this as chain rule so for instance
if I told you okay let's give Y some
actual values some different ones apart
from that let's suppose Y was x squared
minus 1 okay and I've got Y squared in
chain rule what do we usually do we
differentiate the inside let's do this
and then we differentiate the outside
which would be bring the power down
reduce the power by 1 happy so chain
we'll just thought says do the inside
and then do the outside okay I'm gonna
do exactly the same thing here okay it's
just that I don't know what this is okay
well I actually do but I don't need to
know what it is I differentiate the
inside and then the outside what's the
inside function here it's just Y right
that's that's what the inside function
is the outside function is I'm squaring
that okay so the derivative of the
inside function is sinuses plus I'm
taking the derivative off why is that
okay I don't know what it is I don't
need to know what it is it's gonna come
out later okay that's the derivative of
the inside and then I differentiate the
outside so this is something squared how
do you differentiate something with
something squared you bring the power
out the front that's just okay and then
you reduce the power by one okay so this
step here is the this is the implicit
differentiation step right there
okay and it may look confusing because
we haven't you really written stuff like
this before
but it's just chain rule okay
like that you can so put that's not
really teach this method to you because
it's really nothing new
alright now this is to why I'm gonna get
rid of the one because it looks like a -
it's a bit confusing
now what was i after I was after dy/dx
okay so there's the only action right
there okay let me put the Y up the top
so it looks a little more obvious so
Howard do you want yes now that I've
differentiated now I'm going to change
do you mind X to be the subject okay so
I've got let's see what will go here
let's put the 2x on the other side and
3x is that okay and if I would do a DX
upon its own then I just divide through
by 2 y so the twos cancel and I get
minus x over Y so this looks weird okay
because there's still a Y there but it's
still okay because at 3/4 that's my x
coordinate and that's my Y corn there
what's the derivative well it's just
sorry what's the gradient it's just
minus x over Y sir which was easier
probably because you're familiar with
the methods I would suggest at the
moment that this is probably easier than
this they look about the same length
except this it's not a wicked bit in the
middle which is like okay however is
there not to show you with related rates
questions where it's not so simple just
rearranged in implicit differentiation
is really handy okay so